hey friends we are back with another
insta 360 video and today it is for one
of my favorite cameras in the lineup
this is the brand new insta 360 x3 now
they've made a bunch of upgrades since
the last x2 version and i cannot wait to
try them out but first let's unbox and
see what other kind of goodies
are in this bag we've got a full bag of
treats let's unbox it
i can't wait to see this
oh man look at this i love this huge lcd
this is so great oh
my favorite camera in the world
see what else is in the box
we've got our little case
cute this was always one of my favorites
it's just this nice slim little case
that i can just
pop this in this will not only protect
your lcd but also your lenses
look at you look at you you've got a new
home
a little a little microfiber cloth
yes i'm oh i'm so excited they include
the silica gel
my favorite treat and we've got a usb
c cable usb a
2c
let's take a quick look at this camera
before we get into the accessories this
has an all new upgraded half inch sensor
you can shoot 5.7 k 360 degree video
with active hdr 72 megapixel 360 photos
4k single lens mode 8k time lapse it's
waterproof up to 33 feet and has an
all-new 2.29 inch touchscreen with
tempered glass there's also a few new
shooting modes like 4k single lens mode
that will let you shoot wide angle
footage just like a single lens action
camera there's me mode which fixes the
frame to focus only on you and the
selfie stick will be removed this is
great because you can skip having to
reframe in 360 mode and it will all be
automatically done for you there's also
a new 8k 360 degree time lapse 360
degree active hdr 4k 120 frames a second
bullet time and 72 megapixel 360 degree
photo option loop recording will
continually record video that will only
keep the last section up to 30 minutes
to save your memory card space we've
also got a few accessories like this
quick reader mic adapter and the
extended edition selfie stick that lets
you get those impossible fake drone
shots
oh
it's turning on look at this
oh my god i love this touch screen this
is great
i'm very interested in the single lens
mode too which is very interesting i
like that they decided to do that with a
single lens you're basically going to be
turning this into an action camera with
just one lens here's all our different
shooting modes we have video hdr
time lapse time shift bullet time
loop recording star lapse burst
interval hdr and photos let's check out
the accessories the first thing that i'm
going to open is a lens cap protector
this is definitely something
that you're going to want to get even
though this does come with that little
bag to protect it the lenses are
basically the most important part about
these cameras so you do want to protect
them at all costs and that is the cost
of the camera so you're going to want to
protect it okay we're going to open up
the quick reader
you can connect to wi-fi you can
transfer it just like that but with this
it'll be even quicker so you plug this
into your phone plug this into your
insta360 camera and you'll be able to
automatically transfer between the two
which is pretty great so this is a
little adapter that'll let you attach a
microphone
here's the mic adapter which lets you
attach a microphone so you can use like
the wireless go
or any other little wireless microphones
it's so tiny look at that
next up we have the bullet time cord i
haven't done a bullet time test on one
of these in a while this is where you
basically attach the camera to the end
of it and you swing it around your head
and you look absolutely
just ridiculous the shots are worth it
look at that there it is
[Music]
so silly so silly
so now we have a couple selfie stick
options so this is the multi-function
bullet time handle i really like this
one because this doubles as a tripod you
can also do the bullet time shots with
this as well so i like having this kind
of as basically a multi-function tool
it's great
look at that there it is tiny
little tripod
so what's great about this is you can
use the invisible selfie stick which
when you're looking at it it's not
invisible but in post it gets removed so
the selfie stick here you can actually
attach to either side of this if you
want to do the bullet time and not use
full time
little
strings you can also use this and swing
this around your head
so it depends you know
what kind of look you're going for
then you can also attach the selfie
stick to the top
and you can use that as a tripod this
does have a little lock here at the
bottom so you can stop it from rotating
and then this of course will also extend
up quite high
now if this isn't long enough for you
well we have something else this is the
extended edition selfie stick now this
thing is just absolutely super super
cool
it's also incredibly obnoxious which is
why i love it
like
what
like this is so
freaking far
whoops oops oh god okay well um i can
almost touch my desk over there
yup
this is gonna be
so fun so now that i have everything
unboxed all that's left to do is take it
outside and test it out this is gonna be
so much fun i can't wait so we're
outside now and it's time to test and it
is by far the hottest day of the year so
this is going to be quite interesting
hopefully we survive but first things
first
let's test out
the big stick
it hits ground should always do these
motions in like a
soft area in case
[Music]
i have so many friends everyone thinks
that i'm so cool
look at them all
[Music]
so
one of the things i like so much about
this 360 is their app the app is so
intuitive once you get used to it they
have this really cool ai editing feature
called shot lab where it'll give you a
bunch of templates and you basically
follow the instructions and you go shoot
exactly as they tell you and you get a
really cool masterpiece edited together
automatically walking over here as you
may have seen i just downloaded my
footage into the app and automatically
edited together what you just saw this
is one of the things that has been so
unique about this bullet time they can
now have an upgraded 4k 120 frames a
second bullet time feature which is i
think we've all seen the matrix at this
point you take this spin it around your
head
and you're gonna get a really cool
bullet time
[Music]
shot now this does require an extra
little addition so this little bullet
time handle will also double as a tripod
which i love because you can use this to
do things like the clone feature so i'm
gonna walk around this and you'll be
able to clone yourself which is pretty
cool and the app makes it so easy to use
so another accessory if you don't want
to use the bullet time handle is this
this is the insta360 bullet time cord
and it is exactly what the name
says
it's a cord you just screw this into the
bottom and instead of swinging that
around your head you swing this little
cable around your head to get the same
bullet time effect it's pretty awesome
[Music]
i like this as an option because if you
don't have room to carry either the
stick or the tripod the bullet time cord
will get you that same cool effect
another thing that i've liked about this
so far is the increased battery life it
did say that there is a 10 battery
increase which so far we're doing pretty
good and this heat
loves to kill batteries and so far we're
doing pretty well we filmed a bunch of
stuff i've also been importing this
footage into my phone directly using
wi-fi we're still going strong i also
really like how large this lcd is i love
the interface i felt like in the past
the interface was okay but they really
nailed this now because they have so
much more room to give you options like
just being able to click on things the
touch screen seems so much more
responsive so if you have held off and
have always wanted one of these cameras
i feel like the time is now it's here
because this is now giving you the
option to film with a single lens like
you could actually use this as a vlog
camera and i think that may be something
that i might actually consider doing do
you guys miss my vlogs
do you huh huh who does leave a comment
below if you missed my vlogs one of the
cool things about this camera is the
fact that you can also film in single
lens mode you can use either one of the
lenses the front or the back and right
now i'm using the front and it's so cool
because it's basically like an action
camera you can decide which lens to use
and also extend it it's also super
stable
speaking of vlogging if this is
something that you do want to use for
audio the audio has significantly
improved over the past couple versions
of this camera but now they do give you
the option to use a wireless microphone
and they do have an invisible wireless
mount which will give you the ability to
use a microphone to attach this and the
microphone will disappear which is
pretty much the magic of this camera is
invisible selfie stick and now you have
the invisible mic the other thing that i
like about these cameras that i think
sometimes people don't really get is
it's a 360 camera but you don't have to
export that footage in 360. this is one
of those things that i love just taking
out filming i don't have a plan and i'm
just able to take this footage later and
reframe it and that's what i like about
these types of devices is it doesn't
really take you out of the moment
granted it might because you do have a
huge stick and you're flailing it around
but for you you're just filming and
you're gonna have a lot of incredible
content to play with later
[Music]
this is also pretty rugged i have
already hit this off of the grass
several times trying to perform some
maneuvers
oh
which is really cool because i
feel like a lot of these cameras are
used for all types of action sports so
to know that it is pretty durable is
very very great
[Music]
so i'm not good at scootering so this is
all just sort of like
hoping for the best
[Music]
thank you so much for watching this is
the first look at the insta 360 x3 they
now officially did drop the one so these
cameras used to be called the insta360
one and then a number so that's a little
confusing so to alleviate all of the
confusion it is now the insta360 one no
it's not the one oh god i'm confusing
myself insta360 x3 that's it bottom line
definitely my favorite camera so far
every time insta360 releases one of
these cameras they end up being one of
my favorite cameras ever so thank you
insta360 for partnering with me on this
video you guys are always so supportive
and i am such a huge fan of you so thank
you so much for letting me review this
early and i will see you guys in my next
video bye
[Music]
you